hi this is kim from khan academy today
i'm learning about the eighth amendment
to the u.s constitution which prohibits
the government from imposing excessive
fines and bail or inflicting cruel and
unusual punishment on individuals
accused or convicted of a crime but what
counts as excessive or cruel and unusual
to learn more i sought out the help of
two experts on the eighth amendment john
stiniford is the assistant director of
the criminal justice center at the
university of florida law school
john bessler is an associate professor
of law at the university of baltimore
law school so professor bessler why were
the framers so keen to include the
eighth amendment why did they want to
protect these rights in particular well
these rights were actually
enshrined in the english bill of rights
of 1689 and so when the americans got
into dispute with with great britain
they decided they wanted to have the
same rights that
englishmen had and so it was not too
surprising that when
george mason actually wrote the virginia
declaration of rights in 1776 that he
looked to english law to see what rights
the english had because he wanted
exactly the same rights
and so this um 16 words in the eighth
amendment have been subject to a lot of
controversy uh over over the years but i
think one of the reasons that the
founders wanted this was that
like the english who had problems with
the monarch
imposing excessive bail excessive fines
inflicting cruel unusual punishments uh
the founders also knew that was a risk
that uh there was abuse from the
government in the united states and so
they also wanted those rights because
originally in the constitution these
rights were not uh protected against uh
and the uh the bill of rights was
ratified in 1791
which ensured that there would be
protections against these uh cruel
unusual punishments and excessive bail
and excessive fines if you look at the
eighth amendment there's three clauses
right the excessive bail clause the
excessive fines clause and the cruel and
unusual punishments clause and these all
have one thing in common which is that
these are all penalties essentially that
the government inflicts on people
usually as the result of either being
accused of crime
or of being convicted of crimes so if
you've been arrested you're waiting for
trial very often your only way to get
out of jail before before trial is to
make bail
um and of course after you've been
convicted the court might impose a fine
on you um or some other kind of
punishment and so the eighth amendment
is designed to prevent the government
from doing things that are excessive you
know when the government punishes a
person um that's the most coercive thing
the government does short of war right
other than you know shooting you uh in
battle um you know picking you up and
throwing you in a jail cell is about as
bad as it gets and so the framers wanted
to make sure that we had a
constitutional protection when it comes
to criminal punishment so in a lot of
cases in the bill of rights you see the
framers reacting to some historical evil
that they hope to prevent for example
the third amendment says you can't
quarter soldiers in private citizens
homes because that had been such an
important tipping point in the american
revolution was there something that the
framers had in mind as a particular
historical evil that they wanted to
prevent well there are there was some
historical evils and
the english bill of rights
went into place in 1689 and when that
went into place there was actually a
controversy in england around a person
by the name of titus oates titus oates
was somebody who had a false accusation
uh was had committed perjury resulted
actually that allegation of the
execution of 15 catholics uh and
the the plot that he had alleged was one
to assassinate the king
of england the question is what to do
with oats right because as a as a sort
of a moral matter he's about as bad as
it gets in fact in 2005
um english historians voted him the
worst britain of the 17th century and
the um
third worst britain of the last thousand
years or something like that so a very
bad guy you could think of him as a sort
of a serial killer but the problem is
that the actual crime he committed
was the crime of perjury
and even though his perjury resulted in
the deaths of many innocent people
nonetheless he could only be convicted
of perjury which at the time was a
misdemeanor which meant that he could
not be executed for his crime so when it
came time for his sentencing um the
judge
chief justice jeffries who was a famous
hanging judge from english history says
to to oats well oats we can't take your
life we can't take your limb but we have
something special prepared for you
um
and it turns out that what they had
prepared for him was number one a huge
fine they find him like 2 000 marks
they sentenced that he'd be dragged
across the city of london while being
flogged he was dragged from aldgate to
newgate while being flogged and then two
days later just as the scabs were
starting to form on his wounds he's
dragged back across the city of london
from newgate to tyburn again while being
flogged
many people think the hope was that he
would die from the flogging but you know
like a cockroach in a nuclear war he
survived this punishment was actually a
very severe punishment and after the
english bill of rights was promulgated
the titus oates's punishment was
challenged and some of the members of
the house of lords actually called the
punishment barbarous inhuman and
unchristian and contrary to the english
bill of rights and said there was no
precedent to warrant the punishments of
whipping and committing to prison for
life for the crime of perjury this
punishment was eventually remitted in
the sense that oats was later released
although the house of lords refused to
vote to suspend the judgment against
oats because they hated him so much they
said you know so ill a man
shouldn't get the benefit of of of any
relief but they all agreed that the
punishment was cruel and unusual and
what what's interesting is in the debate
they say things like this punishment is
contrary to law and ancient practice
it is without precedent and it'll be a
bad precedent
for the future so in other words
it's cruel and the way we know it's
cruel is because it's so much harsher
than has previously been inflicted for
the crime of perjury right so the odds
case shows us
that when the words cruel and unusual
were first used
they were used to describe punishments
that are harsher
than the common law would permit or
harsher than long-standing prior
practice
would permit
and this means that among other things
the the the cruel and unusual
punishments clause is not limited uh to
gruesome punishments like torture and
the rack and all that kind of thing um
because in fact the punishments
inflicted on oats although they were
very harsh for the crime of perjury
were not as harsh as some other
punishments that the common law
permitted for other crimes like treason
wow so that tells us a lot about the
english context of cruel and unusual
punishment do we know what cruel and
unusual meant to the framers of the u.s
bill of rights
um so punishments
were cruel and unusual again if they're
too harsh in light of long-standing
prior practice
for the crime for which they're
inflicted there's another problem with
statutory law or with decisions of
a judge or a king
or a president for that matter
that's also really relevant when we
think about the eighth amendment and
that is um sometimes the government
gets really mad at someone they either
think of a person as an enemy of the
state and they want to inflict the worst
punishment they can on that person um or
perhaps they are there's a panic about a
certain group in society so for example
in american society recently there have
been panics about drug crime or panics
about sex offenses
and every time that happens the
government tries to respond with new
forms of punishment that are much much
harsher than what came
before
and so the insight behind the eighth
amendment is that when the government
wants to inflict a new punishment you
have to compare it against long-standing
prior practice that is you have to
compare it against the common law right
so the common law was called the law of
custom and long usage right
so if something comported with the
common law it was usual if it was
contrary to the common law it was
unusual and that's where we get the
phrase cruel and unusual punishments
it's basically punishments that are
cruel
in light of or in comparison to
long-standing prior practice so the
basic point of the eighth amendment from
a historical point of view
is to prohibit the government from
innovating in a cruel manner
making up new cruel punishments um in
response to some actual or perceived
provocation by a criminal when the
u.s bill of rights was was adopted
uh many years later many decades later
they had their own issues that they were
struggling with and so
the history shows that the
the american founders probably meant
something different than the english
meant because it was done over 100 years
later but nobody knows exactly
what was meant when they adopted that
wording to give an example when the the
bill was debated in congress a delegate
from south carolina represented from
south carolina said that he objected to
the words nor cruel and unusual
punishments because he said the import
of them was too indefinite
and there was another legislator of mr
livermore from new hampshire
who said that the clause seems to
express a great deal of humanity which
account i have no objection to it but as
it seems to have no meaning in it i do
not think it necessary
what is meant by the terms excessive
bail he asked who were to be the judges
he also asked
what is understood by excessive fines it
lies for the court to determine and so
that's really where we are today in a
lot of ways the court is still deciding
in this case the u.s supreme court is
still deciding what the eighth amendment
language actually means today the modern
case law especially starting in the
1970s revolved a lot around the death
penalty and so the question was is it
still okay to execute people
for for various crimes short of murder
since the 70s the court has continued to
do that in a in a number of areas so it
said you can't execute the mentally
disabled anymore you can't execute
minors
you can't execute anyone for a
non-homicide offense although it's
limited the death penalty in the name of
current standards of decency
it's really not clear how the court
has set about to determine
whether a punishment meets current
standards of decency when the court
is kind of on its own saying that a
punishment
violates current standards of decency
despite the fact that most
democratically elected legislatures
actually approve the practice that it
looks like the court's acting as sort of
a political body it sort of led the
court to ignore what i think is the real
danger of cruelty which is that when
there's a public panic
and the legislature responds by
ratcheting up punishment to new
and unprecedented levels of punishment
and and that's actually happened quite a
lot in the last 40 years and every time
there's a panic you'll you predictably
see the legislatures coming up with new
um punishments that are much much
harsher than what came before um and so
for example with regard to sex offenders
there are now a bunch of states that
actually impose chemical castration as a
form of punishment
for sex offenders now castration as a
form of punishment fell out of usage in
the 13th century
we're literally getting medieval on sex
offenders
but the court can't do anything really
to stop it or at least hasn't um because
uh
these are very popular forms of
punishment you know everyone hates sex
offenders the un has actually
decided that any anything more than 15
days use of solitaire confinement should
not be permitted uh justice anthony
kennedy actually raised the issue of
solitary confinement in recent opinion
he authored for the supreme court he
actually raised the issue on his own at
oral argument at one point
talking about how long people actually
spend in solitary confinement in
american prisons
including including on death row
you have cases actually where
people are spending not just years but
sometimes decades
on death row in these kinds of
conditions
justice breyer just wrote a dissent in a
case where the person had been on death
row for more than 40 years so literally
four decades
in these kinds of very harsh conditions
of confinement
other countries um have
decided that that is not something that
they want to uh permit uh and they've
actually sought out a rule that anybody
that's on death row for a certain number
of years for example would have their
sentence commuted to a life sentence
because of the psychological aspect of
sort of waiting uh for one's own uh own
death
in the bill of rights this is the last
of four amendments actually that are
concerned with protections for the
accused
so why do you think there's so much in
the bill of rights about the justice
system were the framers particularly
interested in making sure that the
accused had rights um yeah they were
and in particular americans were very
devoted to the idea of the common law as
a source
of rights right in fact that's why we
had the american revolution
in the first place was that england was
denying to americans
common law rights like the right
not to be taxed without representation
in parliament but also more specifically
to the criminal law they were denying
them the right to a jury trial in
criminal cases
and so americans wanted to make sure
that when the u.s constitution was
adopted that those common-law rights
that had built up over time in england
would be preserved in the new
american constitutional
order and many of those rights had to do
with criminal law both both criminal
procedures um and to some degree
substantive criminal law and of course
criminal punishments and and again the
reason gets back to sort of what i said
at the beginning which is that when the
government punishes someone that's about
the worst thing it can do
and because you know the early americans
who framed the constitution were very
powerfully concerned with liberty they
wanted to make sure the government would
preserve their liberty
protect their liberty
and uh not become tyrannical right and
so one of the main ways that they wanted
to make sure this happened
was by limiting the power of the
government to punish whoever it wanted
to for any reason that it wanted to and
so we have a
really the majority of the protections
in the bill of rights have to do with
the protections for criminal defendants
what about excessive bail and excessive
fines how can we define what kind of
financial
penalty is
proportionate to a crime
the courts have said essentially they've
looked at dictionary definitions
excessive
means more than is necessary
one of the core principles actually go
back to look at beccaria's work in the
1760s he talked about this idea of a a
scale of crimes and a scale of
punishments and he said that there
should be proportionality between the
two and so that proportionality
principle is one that we're really still
uh wrestling with uh today now the point
of bail is not to um punish someone but
but rather just to make sure that they
will
appear at trial right and so the amount
of money you have to impose
for bail doesn't depend so much on what
crime you committed but what your
financial resources are right it depends
partially on the crime too but but
largely on your financial resources so
the amount of money necessary to make
sure that a poor man appears at trial is
probably going to be much lower than the
amount of money necessary to make sure
that a rich man
appears at trial and so it is a it's a
standard that depends partly on the
nature of the crime but also partially
in the nature
of the offender i imagine that what
seemed like cruel and unusual punishment
in the 18th century
might not be what we consider cruel and
unusual today for example we don't do
whipping as a punishment anymore how has
what counts as cruel and unusual
punishment changed over time the law
really changes gradually over time as
you know and so
when you look back at history they
actually had a large collection of
pretty gruesome punishments uh back in
the uh 18th century
and we had non-lethal corporal
punishments they used things like
branding people they of course
were whipping slaves back then slavery
was still around this is well before the
the civil war ended the institution of
slavery and we also had things like ear
cropping people would you know get their
ears cut off in the crimes act of 1790
which was passed this year before the
ratification of the
eighth amendment the congress actually
authorized public whipping uh lashing of
people and also authorized the pillary
the same punishment that had been used
against titus oates so
there was there was these non-lethal
corporal punishments and really the
death penalty is sort of the last
vestige of
a bodily punishment that the eighth
amendment um
the supreme court has read the eighth
amendment to allow the use of capital
punishment that issue is still a very
live one before the supreme court we're
now seeing challenges about
lethal injection protocols we saw
a challenge to a protocol in kentucky in
2008 we saw one two
uh to a protocol in oklahoma in 2015.
these of course are things that the
founding fathers would never have
envisioned lethal injection typically
involves a three drug cocktail so
there's a barbiturate which is supposed
to put you to sleep there's a paralyzing
agent which paralyzes your body and also
stops your lungs from moving and there's
a heart stopping agent give the offender
all three
and they're supposed to die you know
quickly and painlessly but the problem
is if the sedative doesn't put you
completely
deeply unconscious
then um the other two drugs are likely
to make you suffer quite a bit before
you die and so the question is is this
cruel and unusual or is it not uh cruel
and unusual um and to date the supreme
court has twice held
that lethal injection is not cruel and
unusual and their main reason has been
that the state's not trying to torture
you to death and so if if maybe you're
sometimes accidentally tortured to death
well that's just too bad um but it's not
a cruel and unusual punishment so the
supreme court has approved various
methods of execution at the same time
however the eighth amendment has been
read to protect prisoners so in general
the eighth amendment is sort of a
protective shield that prohibits uh
prison guards from gratuitously beating
up
inmates it
requires prisons to provide some level
of health care to prisoners because they
they cannot get it themselves they're
sort of wards of the state once they're
put in prison uh requires inmates be be
fed and sheltered
so in a lot of ways the eighth amendment
is a protective
shield protecting inmates but then in
the use of the capital punishment it it
becomes what i like to call kind of a
it's kind of a doctor of jekyll and mr
hyde kind of juris prudence that the
eighth amendment has right now
so we've learned that the eighth
amendment seeks to limit the power of
the government in meeting out punishment
to people who have been accused or
convicted of a crime although it's hard
to tell exactly what constitutes
excessive fines or bail in general it's
accepted that those punishments should
be proportional to the crimes in
question today one of the biggest
debates concerns whether or how the
eighth amendment may limit the death
penalty to learn more about the eighth
amendment visit the national
constitution center's interactive
constitution and khan academy's
resources on u.s government and politics